stranded cold and living in miserable
conditions
these people on the bella russian side
of the border with poland are now
getting some help
but it's far from what they want and
need
belarus has housed some in a makeshift
shelter a warehouse with beds blankets
and food but still they try to cross
this footage released by polish
authorities shows people detained as
they crossed the border
there were 501 attempts of illegal
border crossings from belarus in the
last 24 hours
this means the total number of such
attempts in november exceeds 6 000.
but the russian forces also released
this footage
a lithuanian border force dog bites into
a man's sleeping bag lithuanian
authorities say they didn't know someone
was inside
the eu wants to impose more sanctions
and the g7 has condemned belarus
they say it's created the situation on
its borders in what the eu calls a form
of hybrid attack
below russian officials say the
president has offered german chancellor
angela merkel a way forward
the eu will create a humanitarian
corridor for two thousand refugees who
are in the camp we take an obligation
upon ourselves to assist the other five
thousand as much as possible and in case
they are willing to return home
and angela merkel according to the
agreements will hold talks with the eu
including the organization of
humanitarian corridors to germany
but tensions at belarus's borders remain
high
ukraine has deployed national guards to
its border with belarus and lithuania
has also reinforced its border with the
country belarus says it won't force any
migrants or refugees to go back home but
with no solution in sight those who are
trapped are likely to continue to be
used as pawns in a much larger game
assad beg al-jazeera poland